>> Tucker: THE PHARMA COMPANY
ABBOTT LABORATORIES SAYS IT’S
CREATED A NEW PORTABLE
CORONAVIRUS TEST THAT CAN
DELIVER RESULTS IN MINUTES
RATHER THAN DAYS.
SO HOW DOES IT WORK?
DOES IT WORK?
WE DECIDED TO FIND OUT LIVE ON
AIR TONIGHT.
THE ASSOCIATE CHAIR OF POLICY
OUTSIDE BOSTON WILL BE
PERFORMING THE TEST ON THE
SHOW’S CHIEF MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR
DR. MARC SIEGEL.
FOCUS THROUGH WHAT THIS IS, HOW
YOU ADMINISTER IT, WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT.
>> SO THIS IS A RAPID DIAGNOSTIC
TEST THAT WILL GENERATE AN
ACCURATE DIAGNOSIS WITHIN
5 MINUTES IF THE PATIENT IS
POSITIVE FOR COVID AND UP TO
13 MINUTES IF THEY ARE NEGATIVE.
AND IT’S THE ONLY TEST OUT THERE
THAT IS RAPID IN THAT DEGREE OF
SPEED.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU
ADMINISTER IT?
>> SO THE WAY IT WORKS IS THAT
DR. SIEGEL HERE IS KIND ENOUGH
TO BE OUR PATIENT FOR THIS
EVENING AND HAD ACTUALLY
COMPLAINED OF A BIT OF A COUGH
AND IS THINKING ABOUT GOING BACK
IN THE WORDS AT NYU, SO WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA
TO DEFINITIVELY RULE HIM OUT FOR
COVID AND WE ARE GOING TO USE
THE ABBOTT HEARING GET A RESULT
WITHIN A FEW MINUTES.
SO THE WAY IT WORKS IS THAT WE
WILL SWAB HIM AND PUT IT IN THE
INSTRUMENT AND I’M JUST PUTTING
ON MY PPE HERE BECAUSE THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY INFECTIOUS PROCESS,
AND WE WANT ADHERE TO ALL OF OUR
PPE GUIDELINES.
SO THE FIRST STEP HERE IS WE
WILL TAKE A SWAB.
OKAY, SO THE SWAB IS ALL SET NOW
NOW.
>> Tucker: ME I JUST ASK YOU
TO PAUSE THERE.
I SPOKE TO SOMEBODY THE OTHER
DAY WHO HAD ONE OF THESE TESTS
WHERE IT WENT ALL THE WAY INTO
THE BACK OF HIS THROAT.
THAT’S NOT NECESSARILY THIS?
>> SO THAT’S ONE OF THE BEAUTIES
OF THIS INSTRUMENT IS ACTUALLY
IT IS VALIDATED FOR NASAL SWABS.
THE SWAB THAT YOUR MENTIONING
THAT GOES TO THE BACK OF THE
THROAT IS CALLED A
NASOPHARYNGEAL SWAB AND THAT CAN
BE VERY UNCOMFORTABLE AND THAT’S
WHY HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHEN
WE PERFORM AT HAVE TO WEAR PPE
BECAUSE IT CAN INDUCE SNEEZING
OR COUGHING.
>> Tucker: OKAY, SO YOU’RE
GOING TO RUN THAT TEST.
YOU HAVE SOME SORT OF ANSWER IN
10 MINUTES, 15 MINUTES?
>> IN ABOUT 15 MINUTES, WE WILL
PUT IT IN HERE.
WE WILL RUN IT.
HOW SHOW YOU HOW IT WORKS.
SO THE TEST BASICALLY WE OPEN UP
THIS CHAMBER AND WE WILL PUT
SOME REAGENT IN THE BASE EVENT,
WE WILL SWIRL THE SWAB AROUND,
IT HEATS UP, WE MOVE THE TESTING
DEVICE UP INTO THIS TOP ONE.
WE CLOSE IT, PUSH THE BUTTON AND
WALK AWAY AND WITHIN 15 MINUTES,
WE WILL HAVE A RESULT FOR
DR. SIEGEL AND HE CAN BE OFF ON
HIS WAY.
THE BEAUTY OF THE RAPID TEST IS
THAT THEY CAN BE USED IN
MULTIPLE WAYS.
AT MY PARTICULAR HOSPITAL, WE
USE IT FOR INPATIENTS AND FOR
INPATIENTS COMING INTO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM WHO NEED TO BE
QUICKLY ASSESSED WHETHER THEY
HAVE THE INFECTION ARE NOT SO
THEY CAN BE PLACED IN THE
PARTICULAR AREA OF THE HOSPITAL,
IT IS INVALUABLE IN THAT SENSE
AND IT CONCERNS PPE.
WE KNOW WHO WE HAVE TO BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT.
>> Tucker: IT MAKES TOTAL
SENSE AND WE WILL BE BACK IN
JUST A MINUTE TO FIND OUT WHAT
STARTING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
EXACTLY IS HAPPENING TO US.
GORDON CHANG, GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WE’VE GOT A
FOX NEWS ALERT FOR YOU.
DR. SIEGEL’S CORONAVIRUS TEST
RESULTS ARE BACK.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE.
WE ARE JOINED NOW BY OUR CHIEF
MEDICAL CORRESPONDENT WHO IS
BACK TO TELL US WITH THE MASK
OFF.
YOU’RE SMILING.
>> TUCKER, THAT’S A GOOD SIGN.
IT’S NEGATIVE.
AND I WANT TO TELL EVERYONE OUT
THERE WHO WAS WORRIED THEY WERE
IN CONTACT WITH PEOPLE WITH
COVID-19, THIS IS THE WAY THE
FUTURE HAS TO BE.
I FEEL GREAT.
I HAVE BEEN WORRIED FOR A WEEK
NOT WANTING TO COUGH AND PUBLIC,
NOT WANTING ANYONE TO KNOW ABOUT
IT.
THIS MEANS I CAN GO BACK TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND NOT THINK
SO MUCH ABOUT SOCIAL
QUARANTINING WHICH IS WHAT I
WOULD’VE HAD TO DO IF I WERE
POSITIVE.
DR. REDFIELD FROM THE CDC WHO I
SPOKE TO TODAY FEELS THE SWAB I
DID IS JUST AS ACCURATE AS THE
MORE INVASIVE SWAB AND THE
ADMIRAL OF THE HHS SAID THE SAME
THING.
THE OTHER TEST I’M DOING TONIGHT
IS I’M HAVING MY BLOOD DRAWN SO
THAT HE CAN CHECK ME FOR
ANTIBODIES AND THEN I CAN SEE
WHETHER I’M IMMUNE OR ON THE
ROAD TO BEING IMMUNE IF I HAD IT
ALREADY.
THAT’S THE FUTURE HERE.
WE’VE GOT TO KNOW DID I HAVE IT
IN MY GETTING OVER IT?
CAN I GET BACK TO SOCIETY?
IF I HAVE THAT INFORMATION ON
EVERYONE AND LOOK HOW LONG IT
HAS TAKEN NOT EVEN THE LENGTH OF
THE SHOW AND I KNOW I’M NEGATIVE
NEGATIVE.
THAT WILL HELP US RECOVER.
>> Tucker: IT IS A
PREREQUISITE TO RECOVERY.
I KNOW TEN PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
THAT TEST.
VERY QUICKLY, HOW LONG UNTIL
THOSE TEN PEOPLE CAN GET IT?
>> LET’S HOPE WITHIN THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS.
WE ARE TOLD IT WILL BE ROLLED
OUT VERY QUICKLY.
WE CAN ONLY DO FOR AN HOUR ON
THIS BUT WE HAVE 18,000 OF THEM
IN THE COUNTRY.
WE NEED 200,000 AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE OR TEST JUST LIKE IT
FOR RAPID TEST RESULTS.
A POINT OF CARE.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
ABBOTT LABORATORIES, GOOD FOR
THEM.